- My first three
investments were
Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr.
I'm in that,
I'm friends with Zucks.
Friends with Travis from Uber.
Crush It! just
came out and it's killing.
Everything's going great.
I'm at the height, I'm one of
the 20 most followed people on
Twitter and Twitter is
just starting to matter.
Me and my brother start
a client service business.
Like a not super sexy.
Like each shit
from clients all day. Right?
And so, nobody
could've raised more
money than me in 2009 and '10.
I'm at the top of my game and
I took four steps back including
being ridiculed and made fun of
by my internet famous friends,
I went and built VaynerMedia.
We kind of struggled with
it for the first two years
because it was hard.
It was a big humble
pie that I had to eat.
I had to go into brand manager
meetings and it was crazy for
where I was in my career.
But I was self-aware to know
what I was capable of building
that would be successful.
And in the 48 months
since I've really run it,
it's been alive for six years,
I've grown that company
from 30 to 650 employees
from $3 to $100
million in revenue.
And not pass through revenue
of media, we do $100 million.
And in current 2.5 to 3 time
revenue valuations for agencies,
it's a $250 to $300 million
valuation with a business that's
gonna to kick $17 million
in profit this year.
That me and my brother my
partner, right, and that one
you can clap because that was
real execution in the face of
a lot of sexy
other things to do.
And I wasn't a kid,
I had already made it and
I still went practical.
The level of practicality the
level of self-awareness,
the level of patience,
the level of humility,
the level of
empathy to the market
and gratitude for
your opportunities and
the level of understanding
what's understanding in
the macro and micro economic
climate in our space is shit.
(light music)